sigan protegiendo se es el mensaje de
las autoridades chilenas que advierten
que a pesar de que alrededor del 25% de
la población ha recibido ya al menos una
dosis de la vacuna los ciudadanos no
deben bajar la guardia todavía en la
lucha contra el coronavirus hay que
tener mucho cuidado de no caer en el
exitismo el gobierno ha cometido errores
en el pasado de compararse con otras
argentinas le daba lecciones hace un par
de meses atrás de que ellos tenían un
mejor sistema sanitario de la mejor 40
mediodía tiene una mortalidad desatada
el chileno comerá hoy el error para
ayudar a detener un mayor aumento de
nuevos casos chile ha introducido
medidas de cuarentena para todos los
viajeros procedentes de brasil el país
más afectado por la pandemia de américa
latina a partir de hoy día a las 5 de la
mañana todos los viajeros que llegaron
que llegan desde brasil o que han estado
en brasil los últimos 14 días deben irse
a una residencia sanitaria tanto
chilenos como extranjeros en la
residencia sanitaria se les tomará una
pcr y aquellas personas que salen
negativo pueden continuar su cuarentena
en el aislamiento donde está decidido
por las personas las personas que salen
positiva en establecer deben continuar
su aislamiento en la residencia
sanitaria esto se produce cuando las
salas de la uci con pacientes de
coronavirus informaron de un promedio de
ocupación del 93 5% y algunas regiones
informaron de hasta un 18% más de casos
de comida en los últimos días hasta el
jueves chile ha registrado más de 860
mil casos de kobe y más de 21 mil
muertos